it seemed like everyone and their mother
was advertising established titles this
year is it a scam yes is it illegal
maybe established titles has taken over
YouTube extremely prominent YouTubers
have run sponsorships for the company
and the money was flowing like many
YouTubers I had been approached
repeatedly about running and established
titles sponsorship if it's no Scots it's
just crap I declined because it didn't
make much sense to me and started
researching my own video on the topic
and that was until Scott Shaffer made a
video calling established titles a scam
it pretty much blew up the internet this
company is a complete scam so is
established titles really a scam well
that's what we're gonna figure out here
today now it's actually hard to explain
what established titles does without
already jumping into value judgments so
I'll let establish titles explain in its
own words established titles owns less
than 200 acres of land in rural Scotland
their website says that you can buy a
dedicated one foot by one foot square
souvenir plot of land from them and it
also states that you can quote become a
lord or lady today they say that their
packages are quote based on a historic
Scottish land owner ownership custom
where land owners have been long
referred to as lairds the Scottish term
for Lord with the female equivalent
being lady okay so let's start at the
beginning when you're talking about
false advertising or fraud in Commerce
you're probably talking about one of two
laws section 43a of the Lanham act
authorizes civil suits for false
advertising they quote misrepresents the
nature characteristics qualities or
Geographic origin of goods or services
states have their own laws regulating
false advertising and other deceptive
trade practices for example California
business and professions Code 17 500 AKA
false advertising law the fal prohibits
false and misleading statements
generally in connection with any good
services and or real or personal
property now to understand whether
advertising is false or misleading you
have to look at the claims that are
being made when it comes to established
titles there are several different
sources of potential claims their
website advertisements and YouTube
sponsorships and we'll look at each of
those in turn
well the homepage in the hero Banner
states that you can quote save these
Scottish woodlands and quote become a
lord today a prior version of the
website said become a lord or lady today
you can quote purchase a personal
lordship or ladyship title pack with
dedicated land in Scotland the asterisk
direct you to fine print right below it
says a quote this is a purchase for a
personal dedication for a souvenir plot
of land you may choose to title yourself
with the title of Lord Laird or lady and
as I said before the website States
quote this is based on a historic
Scottish land ownership custom where
landowners have been long referred to as
lairds the Scottish term for Lord with
the female equivalent being lady on the
purchase page it states quote each Lord
title pack includes a dedicated plot of
land measuring one square foot five
square feet or ten square feet a
personalized title certificate with your
name or the name of the title holder a
unique plot Number that will be assigned
to the title holder your digital
certificate will be emailed to you
within 24 hours we plant a tree for
every order a digital personalized
member's handbook additionally they have
an entire terms of service page on the
website as well with further detail now
taking this all together there is an
implication that by purchasing a small
plot of land through his apples titles
you become officially recognized as a
Scottish Noble or Lord they don't
explicitly state that and in many ways
they explicitly walk that back and
there's also an implication of owning a
piece of Scottish real estate I'd call
that ambiguous but we'll talk about that
later now they do explicitly state that
you can buy a certificate that you get a
dedicated plot of land and that they
plant a tree for every purchase now
before digging into the claims let's
clear a few things up putting aside for
the moment whether established titles
makes any such Claims can you become a
lord related through purchasing Scottish
land novelty or otherwise no not like
this now first off I am not a lawyer in
the UK or a barrister or a solicitor or
an advocate or any of the other strange
words that they use in the ridiculous
English legal system
soccer the entire idea of nobility or
listening to anything that this guy says
is silly and quite frankly Un-American
but there is an authority on this
particular ridiculous subject that is
the court of the Lord lion which deals
with all matters relating to Scottish
heraldry and coats of arms and that
Court said quote ownership of a souvenir
plot of land does not bring with it the
right to any description such as Laird
Lord or lady Laird is not a title but a
description applied by those living on
and around the estate many of whom will
derive their living from it to the
principal landowner of a long-named area
of land it will therefore be seen that
it is not a description which is
appropriate for the owner of a normal
residential property it cannot properly
be used to describe a person who owns a
small part of a larger piece of land the
term Laird is not one recognizable by
attachment to a personal name and thus
there is no official recognition of XY
layered of Zed the words Lord and Lady
apply to those on whom peerage has been
confirmed and do not relate to the
ownership of Lynn ownership of a
souvenir plot of land is not sufficient
to bring a person otherwise ineligible
within the justification of the Lord
lion for seeking a coat of arms but what
about that historic Scottish land
ownership custom that established titles
talks about well that's just wrong too a
representative of the court of Lord Lyon
stated in response to another
established title Style company quote
the title Laird of Glencairn would only
apply to the owner of the entire estate
if it exists not those buying one foot
portions of it now you can become a lord
or lady through inheritance or marriage
or Royal Decree but not from a Black
Friday sale from established titles a
monarch can give a person a period such
as a Duke a Marquez a role viscounter
Baron and sometimes people with
hereditary titles sell them usually
because they have financial problems
these titles sell for tens of thousands
of dollars okay but what about the
implication of land ownership do you own
the land now again putting aside the
issue of whether established titles
makes this particular claim that you are
actually buying the land are you
actually buying the land well
established titles has just under 200
Acres now I looked around in rural land
in Scotland can cost about ten thousand
dollars per acre therefore established
titles several hundred acres probably
cost around two million dollars funny
enough Katarina Yip the CEO of stylish
titles also runs landassets.com which
sells real land in Scotland in one to
two acre Parcels now my guess here and
this is just pure speculation is that
they probably buy up the land in bulk
and either use it for established titles
or sell it in slightly larger chunks as
actual real estate so with respect to
the one foot by one foot Parcels no you
don't own the land it's too small to be
registered in Scotland and get a deed
for it instead you get a contractual
dedication from established titles this
means basically nothing it's like buying
an mp3 from Apple music you have a
contract they will provide a certain
thing to you a song do you own it no no
you don't not in any real sense now in
this context the Journal of the Law
Society of Scotland says quote there
have been a few articles in the media
recently about companies who were
selling off tiny pieces of land known as
souvenir plots in the highlands some
websites suggest that ownership of the
plot carries with it the right to use
the title of layered Lord or lady given
that some websites claim that the land
registration Scotland Act of 1979
removes the normal requirements to
register your land thus permitting the
sale to take place under contract law
the keeper would like to clarify her
position on the subject a souvenir plot
is defined in the land registration
Scott Act of 1979 as a piece of land
which being of inconsiderable size or no
practical utility is unlikely to be
wanted in isolation except for the sake
of mere ownership or for sentimental
reasons or commemorative purposes the
keeper is required to reject an
application for registration in the land
registry if the land to which it relates
meets the description of souvenir plot
However the fact that the keeper is
obliged to reject the registration does
not necessarily mean that ownership can
be obtained by some other means a real
right of ownership can land in the sense
of a right that is enforceable against
third parties can only be obtained by
registration in the land registry or by
recording a deed in the register of
signs as appropriate solicitors who are
consulted by a client in relation to the
purchase of a potential souvenir plot
should bear in mind that in some cases
the land in question might not be of
inconsiderable size in such cases no
exemption from registration applies in
other words the land registry act that
established titles relies on defines a
souvenir plot of land in the context of
the things that the register of land
will necessarily reject it doesn't
affirm relatively mean that a souvenir
plot of land is something the law will
actually recognize all it means is that
it won't qualify as real estate what you
get at most is a personal right a
contractual right against the actual
landowner of established titles you do
not get a real ownership of interest
that is you don't own the land
established titles is making a contract
with you that they won't develop your
tiny portion of the land and will record
your name in their own private registry
you know what
they're actually making land nfts that's
basically what they're doing and then
next there's a question of does
established titles plant the trees that
they claim well sort of yes the very
first headline on the website is save
the Scottish Woodlands they also purport
to plant a tree with every purchase many
people have assumed that this means that
the company is planting a tree on the
tiny plots of land that is assigned to
them if you read through the entire
website it becomes clear that this isn't
true established titles donates money to
third parties who plant trees now their
website is replete with pictures of
forests and lists several addresses that
appear to correspond to wooded land in
Scotland and I have no reason to believe
that this is false now for several years
the established titles website said it
had donated over 42 000 pounds to these
tree planting services but suddenly in
late November 2022 they changed their
website copy to reflect that they were
responsible for over 2 million trees
being planted now it's clear when you
look at the language that they work with
third parties who specialize in tree
planting now there's nothing inherently
wrong with that and in fact you'd
probably want that delegation of Labor
these Services could probably plant
trees much cheaper than anybody else
except that the language that
established titles uses is often
misleading in fact the CEO admitted that
the language was misleading especially
when Modified by YouTubers I think we'll
have to like rephrase that or look at
what we're saying and try to make it
clearer okay but let's go off on a quick
tangent if you'll indulge me let's talk
about how much money does established
titles make well the answer I think is a
lot The Savage titles is currently owned
by a venture capital firm based in Hong
Kong called Galton voicing it's this
company that was reaching out to
YouTubers to do sponsorships for
established titles now I've talked to
many creators and I know that
established titles was sometimes paying
five and six figures for sponsorships
for the bigger Youtubers with bigger
views sometimes 75 000 to over a hundred
thousand dollars per video sadly they
only offered me seven thousand dollars
per video and my friend Rowan who is a
cardiatric surgeon 3500 so you know the
lawyers win again but as it happens your
boy here isn't just a lawyer he's also a
content creator who runs sponsorships
and is an expert in the Creator economy
so let's dig in let's make some educated
guesses about the business of
established titles in response to all
this backlash the CEO of established
titles wrote a letter to creators saying
quote gelton Boise has supported us
since day one even though they knew that
their initial funding for this
conservation project would most likely
lead to financial loss this year alone
gelton Boise has made a multi-million
dollar loss on established titles
sponsoring all those videos isn't cheap
and you know what she's right those
sponsorships are expensive and they've
sponsored hundreds of videos to the tune
of four five and six figure deals so
let's talk about profit or loss I'm a
little bit skeptical here now as I
mentioned established titles boasts of
over 2 million trees being planted in
response to their business we know that
the upper limit of the cost per tree is
one dollar per tree that figure comes
directly from one tree planted the
company that established titles works
with to plant trees now I have no reason
to think that either the 42 000 pounds
being donated or the 2 million trees
numbers is wrong I suspect that they
realize that 2 million trees sounds way
more impressive than 42 000 pounds so
they change the language on the website
to reflect that that makes sense but
because of that I think we can easily
figure out how much of a cash cow
established titles is they say that
they're responsible for over 2 million
trees we know that it costs at most one
dollar per tree and probably less now
the minimum that you can spend on
established titles is 50 for a digital
only certificate if you wanted that
printed out and shipped to you that
costs an extra thirty dollars if you
want that piece of paper framed that
costs an extra fifty nine dollars for a
total of a hundred and thirty nine
dollars now you can also buy larger
plots of land for more money but at
least the printing out and the
certificate in the frame upsells cost
thirty dollars and fifty nine dollars
respectively with hundreds of dollars in
extra upsells if you want five or ten
square foot packages or a couple's
package then at the checkout page you're
automatically signed up for an eight
dollar recurring charge to plant one
tree per month until you cancel now as
an aside I found this automatic addition
to my cart to be particularly galling
because the language makes it sound like
it's the tree planting that is already
included with your purchase in other
words when I was checking out and yes I
did purchase one of these things I
thought they listed the tree with every
order in my cart as as a separate item I
had to read the small print to realize
that this was an upsell of a monthly
recurring Eight dollar cost for one tree
being planted every month now the fact
that they have planted over two million
trees means that they've made
approximately two million individual
sales now granted this number might be
off if they made a separate donation of
trees on their own but if they had
they'd probably be shouting it from the
mountain tops and admittedly that upsell
of a monthly tree will drive that dollar
per sale number down so let's be
extremely conservative and say that
there are two trees per sale in other
words two million trees being donated
means that they've sold at least one
million individual sales so to figure
out the revenue and profit you can
generally multiply the number of sales
roughly two trees per sale by how much
they make on each sale so how do we
figure that out well given that the
minimum that you can spend on a digital
certificate that costs zero marginal
dollars is fifty dollars and the sheer
number of upsells that also cost almost
zero marginal dollars I think that the
average cart value is easily a hundred
dollars plus now factor in fulfillment
of maybe a couple dollars per order for
a cheap frame and shipping then takes
them off the top for overhead then the
biggest expense is marketing the
sponsorships now it's not unusual to
spend 30 to 50 of Revenue on marketing
for a high margin instant profit product
like this and then they probably spent
about two million dollars on 200 acres
in Scotland all told they're probably
looking at revenue of roughly a hundred
dollars per purchase and a net profit of
about fifty dollars per purchase yes
that probably means that over the last
three years they have revenue of roughly
100 million dollars with profit easily
exceeding 50 million dollars but look
that's just a guess my assumptions could
be wrong you can do the math yourself
but at base I think established titles
is wildly profitable with a large
expense being marketing but the benefit
of that marketing is that you can easily
scale it up or down and make instant
profit and they could easily be making
two dollars for every one dollar that
they spent they clearly make a large
margin on every single sale that they
make and there's even a plaque on Galton
Boise's office tour in their website we
see that even as far back as 2020 and
2021 before this huge boom in YouTube
sponsorships established titles was
regularly making a over a million
dollars in quarterly profit and it was
their most profitable company so now we
get to the heart of the matter does
established titles engage in false or
misleading advertisements their website
States right in front become a lord
today and that's not technically true
you can't become a lord the implication
is that established titles has found
this one weird trick this funny little
league loophole that lets you become
Scottish nobility but implications are
not necessarily false advertising and
there is a subsequent language that
claws this back further down on the
website and they say that it's based on
but not necessarily following an ancient
Scottish custom and they say that it's a
purchase for a personal dedication for a
souvenir plot of land and you may choose
to title yourself with the title of Lord
Laird or lady and it's true that they
will dedicate whatever that means a plot
of land to you they imply that you own
the land though they don't outright say
that and that historic custom language
is weird though where landowners have
been long referred to as Laird's the
Scottish term for Lord with a female
equivalent being lady I mean in what
sense you're not really buying the land
so why is this custom even relevant or
being displayed on the website I mean
obviously we know why it's there but
syntactically what is it doing but look
there are good arguments on both sides
here from established title side the
purchaser does get certain rights
related to their plot of land Yip
explains that should established titles
ever attempt to sell the land that your
square foot is on you can sue them while
you don't actually get a deed or plot
registration by possessing some
contractual rights over the square you
do to some degree own that land now the
bit about becoming a lord is a fun
premise but it's pretty silly once you
realize that it would mean that
literally anyone that owned land in
Scotland would be a lord or a lady which
doesn't make any sense well it's a
well-known fact Sunny Jim that there's a
secret society of the five wealthiest
people in the world known as the
pentavrett who run everything in the
world including the newspapers and me
try annually at the secret country
mansion in Colorado no dads The Meadows
but that leads into one of the best
offenses which would be that it's so
ridiculous on its face that no one would
be confused about what they were buying
no one seriously thought that they were
actually going to become Scottish
nobility I hated the colonel with his
Wikipedia guys and their website is
pretty clear about implying a real Noble
title but never actually saying it and
then you know having lots and lots of
disclaimers to claw that back anyway but
it's funny you know once I started
researching established titles I started
getting tons of targeted advertising and
in this case it was actually very
helpful in these two targeted ads that I
received there were even bigger gaps
between what was advertised and what
consumers were actually getting when you
buy land in Scotland you are legally
referred to as a lawyer lady so this I
bought Square for the land where they're
gonna play a train so if you were
legally referred to as lordland
the advertisement state with zero
qualifications that you will own a
specific unit of land in Scotland with
your purchase and become a Lord that
advertisement has nothing about getting
a contractual right to a dedication and
the ad also implies causation between
buying a piece of land false and then
becoming a lord also false but In
fairness established titles terms and
conditions clarify these claims on the
website in small prints saying quote the
purchase of a title pack from
established titles does not constitute
or trigger a transfer of ownership over
that souvenir plot or any part of the
land in the legal sense the website also
describes this Lord package as quote a
fun novelty product though it is pretty
sneaky that they title their products a
lordship package and a lady ship package
without actually bestowing a lordship or
a lady ship but the website also
describes these packages as quote a fun
novelty product that the purchase is a
personal dedication for a souvenir plot
of land and the individual quote may
choose to title yourself with the title
of Lord Laird or lady but arguably these
disclosures contrary the plain text of
these ads which say that you will own
Scottish land and you will become a Lord
with your purchase and contradicting the
plain text of an advertisement is a
No-No when it comes to false advertising
and furthermore the ads inclusion of a
formal certificate gives the impression
that a person buying the certificate
will literally be a lord or lady or of
Scottish land and but hold on because
some of their ads are even worse and I
have the receipts more on that in a
second and a lot of people have noted
that established titles business evokes
comparisons with the famous register of
star company where basically you're just
paying this company so you can put your
name associated with some star in a
again a private registry not the
official place where stars are actually
named but while a person literally can't
own a piece of the Galaxy becoming a
lord is a real thing that you can do in
real life and again the clear
implication of established titles
advertisements is that if you pay them
money you will literally become a lord
or a lady and in fact in the FAQ section
of established title's website the
company encourages purchasers to refer
to themselves as Lords or ladies on
official documents including credit
cards and airline tickets now I got a
hold of the Creator brief that
established titles gave to various
YouTube creators when they were running
established title sponsorships and in
that brief established titles says
specifically that the Creator can't say
that you can change your name on your
passport or when applying for bank loans
and as the CEO confirmed in an interview
the reason is because there isn't a drop
down menu when you're choosing your
options on a passport and most common
law jurisdictions you can toggle
yourself however you want to title
yourself as long as you're not well as
long as you're doing it in good faith
and you're not using it to try to get a
bank loan or try to get someone to
invest like way more than they would
have you know trying to make a trying to
make you something seem trustworthy and
make someone else
um basically give you funds for that uh
by using the word sorry using the Lord
or lady title
um but if you're doing it in good faith
if you're putting it on like a plane
ticket or credit card you can
technically call yourself whatever you
want to call yourself rather sorry very
specifically you can title yourself
however you want to title yourself but
if it's not actually possible why you
need to warn people not to do that and
then they say that you can't do it when
applying for a bank loan because you
can't seem to be more trustworthy than
you are and you can only do things in
good faith but under what circumstances
can you ever say that you are a lord or
a lady in good faith based on
established titles products it's either
a joke or gimmick or you can do it in
good faith it can't be both so that
takes us to the defenses established
titles has vigorously pushed back
against claims that it has engaged in
false or deceptive advertising and is
otherwise a scam and admittedly they
have strong defenses after Scott
shaffer's video on November 24th 2022
the founder of established titles
Katarina Yip sent a letter to creators
and she described the package as a fun
gift meant for a good laughed Miss Yip
further states that it's consumers
understand that they aren't literally
becoming a Scottish Lord or lady
suggesting any belief to the contrary
would be unreasonable quote we have
always been clear that our certificates
are based on a historic Scottish custom
I'm calling landowners Laird's Lords or
ladies and that it does not Grant you
the right to rule or make you a member
of any royal family nor the right to a
peerage and there's no doubt that a lot
of people saw this as a gag gift and
therefore did not buy that's not false
advertising that could be described as
accurate advertising and people making a
reasonable decision not to purchase now
A friend of mine who ran an established
title spot explain it like this quote
I'm sure from a lawyer perspective
you're pulling your hair out at the you
can own land claim but I think the rest
of us think of this as a silly gimmick a
feature or bug of late stage capitalism
where people are looking to spend their
disposable income on weird [ __ ] like
feeling a part of some souvenir plot of
land in a beautiful far away place that
feels formal and is potentially
contributing to some preservation effort
but I honestly don't even think the
conservation thing is even an appeal
people find Value in weird stuff and
again I don't think anyone is earnestly
purchasing established titles or any of
their competitors yes there are several
it appears thinking they now own land
and are literally a lord if anyone is
selling it like that I agree that's
misleading but it's hard to call
established titles snake oil or scam
when it's so clearly a silly gimmick now
I think this is a totally fair way of
looking at it and it's an interpretation
that's bullied by all the disclaimers on
the established titles website a lot of
the critics of established titles saw no
value in purchasing from established
titles and therefore didn't purchase but
they then assume that everyone who did
purchase must have been a complete idiot
and been misguided but I think my
friends interpretation recognizes the
agency of the buyers and the value
propositions of established titles and
all that is totally reasonable and in
the November 2022 interview with a
British YouTuber Katarina Yip states
that established titles has always
classified this Lord lady package as a
novelty item we've always been very
clear on the website that this is a
novelty item
um and I think that
the language really hasn't changed since
day one but there are some problems with
this defense in that brief they include
a section on common errors to avoid and
section two says quote the phrase
royalty or nobility our certificate is
based on a historic Scottish custom of
calling landowners Lords or ladies it
does not Grant you the right to rule or
make you a member of any royal family
our certificates also do not Grant you
peerages of the United Kingdom now first
I think that there's an argument to be
made that the reason that they have to
tell creators not to say this is because
they know that they are creating a lot
of confusion in the marketplace now
arguably people have been misled it also
undercuts the argument that the term
Lord is ambiguous in general I think it
would be a good defense to say that Lord
or lady is an ambiguous term subject to
multiple definitions one of which
established titles meets but I think
most people understand it to mean the
nobility associated with peerage which
established titles tells creators
specifically not to say though on the
other hand this is also evidence that
established titles is being careful and
affirmatively avoiding confusion but a
second problem with this defense is that
the content creators who have the been
sponsored by established titles often
use the word officially or real in the
context of the lordship as in officially
a lord or now I'm a real lord thanks to
an old Scottish custom means that you or
the person you're buying the land for
officially becomes what's known as a
Laird that's a lord or lady for us
Modern English speakers you could
officially become a lord or a lady too I
am a 100 authentic Scottish Lord this
official certificate making you a real
lord or lady I think they use that
language which is not included in the
talking points because that's kind of
what it seems like they're selling and I
suspect that they were confused and or
misled and like all sponsors established
titles has a duty to supervise the
sponsorship integration at least the
part of the video that they have
specifically sponsored and according to
the creators that I've talked to they do
review every video before it goes live
this is because companies are legally
responsible for the portions of the
videos that they sponsor and the words
that those creators say in that context
in other words when a Creator says
established titles will make you a real
lord or you'll officially become a lord
they own that language even though it's
arguably contrary to the provided
talking points some sponsorships lean
into the conservation aspect but a lot
of the sponsorships on YouTube focus on
lordship and many go hard on becoming
official or real in fact the CEO admits
that this is the main criticism of
people is that the titles are not
official titles and yet tons of creators
use those terms and use that kind of
language but where could those creators
have gotten that wrong idea from well
remember that I mentioned that there
were some even worse more dubious
established titles ads well here you can
see that established titles does in fact
use the language of official lordship
and legal lordship pretty often when you
buy land in Scotland you are legally
referred to as a lord or lady so this I
bought Square for the land where they're
gonna play a train
so you were legally referred to as Lord
lamb
can you guess how I became a lord at
just age 19
I would probably have to guess that you
inherited the position because your
father before you actually established
titles sell the title that could
officially make you a lord or a lady on
top of this since you're officially a
lord or a lady you have dedicated land
in Scotland you will literally get a
certification that makes you a lord or a
lady pretty cool right yeah
I love it I've always wanted to be a
lady
hat tip to Scott Shafer for finding some
of those ridiculous ads and they
consistently say that you officially
become a lord or that you are legally a
lord no disclaimers so while in general
established title says that you can
refer to yourself as a Lord and maybe
the term Lord Laird or lady is open to
interpretation claiming that you are
officially allured or legally a lord is
quite another stronger claim altogether
no I suspect there are a good number of
people who read the established titles
website or ads and thought yes Noble
titles are silly but according to this
legal loophole I can be a real Noble too
and if true that could have been the
result of misleading advertising in part
I know this because established titles
blog specifically says quote you won't
believe this legal loophole in Scotland
I mean I guess technically that's true
because I don't believe them but they go
on quote there's a small legal loophole
in Scotland that makes it possible for
anyone to title themselves as Lord or a
lady through this loophole anyone can
buy a small plot of land in Scotland and
refer to themselves as a lord or a lady
further more stating that your product
is a novelty on the website doesn't
necessarily cure the issue of
established titles advertising campaigns
that suggest you literally become
nobility and as the FTC has made very
clear you cannot advertise in one way
and have disclaimers that say something
else on your website particularly if you
have to scroll to find it now perhaps
it's true that absolutely no one thought
they were a real lord or lady but given
established titles marketing campaigns
and the sponsored creators who suggest
that this is anything but a novelty I
definitely wouldn't hang my hat on that
defense now another defense in
established title's favor is that people
accurately view this purchase from
established titles as a pro-conservation
gift and as far as I can tell you do get
at least one tree planted with every
purchase they probably have purchased
200 acres in Scotland they do work with
third-party tree planting Services which
appear legitimate you're not getting
nothing for your purchase you are
contributing to environmental causes
with a cheeky nonsense nobility thing
thrown in for kicks the CEO explains
what they actually do which isn't
necessarily A Bad Thing buying land and
then Contracting to never develop it but
when asked about about consumer
confusion the CEO waffles for almost a
full minute trying to dance around all
of the confusion do you think that that
is a little bit of uncleanness
um in terms of
what it is because essentially you guys
are the Lords and Ladies of that land
you're the ones who own it so do you
think there is a little bit of
um
misunderstanding or miscommunication do
you think maybe to the audience as to
what their true status is around that
because I feel like a part of it does
rely on individuals knowing the laws
around this and not everybody does I I
certainly didn't
that's a really fair uh question so I
think we're very clear about that in our
FAQs
um we talk about how souvenir plots work
um and and how we take our obligations
to our Lords and Ladies very seriously
so I wouldn't say that we are the
um like Lords and Ladies of the land we
are the title holders that's a thing
like legally we can't do what we want
with it so you know how that we
contractually entered sorry now that
we've entered into a contractual
obligation to specific people
or the stuff that normally let's say
flows with
owning or being the title holder of a
plot purely doesn't apply here
um so
I understand what you're saying about
um
it perhaps
um
like
I I understand what your your
saying about
are the
um
customers the real owners if you own the
title but I think the way we see it is
we take our contractual obligations
extremely seriously no I commend this
YouTuber for engaging in this interview
and trying to do the research and going
back to the source and actually getting
first-hand information but even she
admits that it's confusing and that
they're aware of others being confused
and that established titles needs to
update the talking points because
they're confusing um I just think that
that's probably one of the parts that's
a little bit confusing because there's
there's some people I I mean even people
who may have purchased through myself
who has felt like Oh I thought like
there might have been like even if I
can't really use it there might have
been a little bit of legitimacy behind
it now I've seen a lot of people
criticize established titles saying that
if you really cared about environmental
causes you would just skip establish
titles altogether and donate directly
now I'm of two minds about this because
first of all that's not how charity
works sometimes you have to throw a
party that costs a million dollars to
entice guests to donate three million
dollars you might not like the waste or
the inefficiency but sometimes you need
a reason to incise people to give an
establish title CEO said quote in the
past two years we have done more
tangible work in the preservation of the
woodlands in Scotland than anyone else
to our knowledge this includes donating
to plant over 2 million trees and
acquiring over hundreds of acres of land
and contractually committing to preserve
it in its natural state this year we are
slated to be trees for the Futures
giving Tuesday partner matching all
donations up to fifty thousand dollars
it's a shame that this attempt to cancel
us will make these efforts in the future
that much harder okay sure but let's
talk about orders of magnitude here now
as I said before I'm guessing that the
average card value is about a hundred
dollars it costs a maximum of one dollar
per tree to plant a tree so you're
talking about roughly one to two percent
of the revenue of this company going to
tree planting the less than 200 Acres
that established titles owns is roughly
0.3 square miles not three square miles
0.3 square miles in a part of Scotland
that doesn't see that much development
anyway so let's be real here established
titles is far more of a money-making
Venture than it is in environmental
charity so is established title as a
scam I mean it seems like it at least
colloquially a scam is is defined as a
dishonest scheme A Swindle so probably
it seems like there's some dishonesty
there is it illegal well there are some
good arguments to that effect and look
established titles is not the only one
out there there's a million of these
different companies highlandtitles.com
scotlandtitles.com all direct and
Defenders have said it's only as much of
a scam as the name of star Registries or
nfts to which I say correct most of
those are scams as well and the funny
thing is on the internet everyone always
screams class action lawsuit and class
action lawsuit never makes sense in the
context that people think it does but
here if people were deceived that is
exactly the kind of thing that actually
would work as a class action except
buried in the small print in the terms
of service on establisheditles.com is a
class action arbitration waiver though I
do question whether that would be
enforceable in this context and even if
it's not outright illegal it's terrible
for creators at large some creators in
the wake of apologizing for running an
established title sponsorship have
admitted that they will basically take
any sponsorship that comes their away I
get a sponsorship opportunity for almost
anything I'm gonna take it and that's
the Creator's right they can run
whatever sponsorship they want to or
decide not to run whatever sponsorship
they want to but the thing is it hurts
the entire Creator economy because when
very prominent YouTubers promote crap
everyone assumes that all the
sponsorships are crap and I've seen lots
of comments to the effect that the
viewer just automatically assumes that
everything any YouTuber promotes is just
direct and that's not fair to the people
who are running legitimate sponsorships
and to that point look my sponsors are
legitimate if I say that I use them I
actually use them and not to be holier
than thou but I'm represented by nebula
talent in full disclosure I'm a large
minority owner but literally no one
represented by nebula Talent ran and
established titles sponsorship Now Fair
established titles was risable on its
face but at the same time the CEO of
nebula Talent Dave Whiskas kept telling
everyone not to burn their reputation on
what was at best a gimmick or a gag gift
because once you lose your credibility
you never get it back and there's not
just reputational risk there's also
counterparty risk and wouldn't you know
it established titles has now pulled all
of their sponsorships for 2022 because
of all of this backlash they're actively
breaking contracts they had with
creators though at the same time they're
also letting creators out of their
contracts if they want so it was good
while it lasted I hope it was worth it
but look on the bright side there's
always rage Shadow Legends but it's been
a long day at the office and all this
talk of scams and fake environmental
Charities has me wishing that there was
a way to know which Charities were worth
it and how to maximize my donation
dollar to do the most good possible
if only there was a way to do that well
luckily there is today's legitimate
sponsor givewell does exactly that give
will spends over 40 000 hours each year
researching charitable organizations and
only recommends a few of the highest
impact evidence-based Charities that
they found over a hundred thousand
donors have used givewell to donate more
than one billion dollars with a b and
ensure that their donations have made
Maximum Impact to save tens of thousands
of lives and improve the lives of
millions more and here's the best part
givewell is completely free give well
helps allocate your tax deductible
donation to the charity that you choose
without taking a cut they publish all
their research and recommendations on
their site for free no sign up required
and when you donate through givewell
your donations are still tax deductible
in the US and they'll match your
donations up to a hundred dollars
givewell's top recommendation is to
donate to their all grants fund which
can be allocated to Any Grant that meets
their cost effect in this bar and my
recommendation is to give their top
Charities fund which direct donations to
the charity or Charities the givewal has
determined to be the most effective each
quarter give well is transparent about
how donations are spent and how their
decisions are made they even have a web
page devoted to sharing the mistakes
that they've made along the way give
well simplifies the process of finding
and giving to outstanding Charities
because they do the independent research
they give me peace of mind that my
donations will do the maximum good
because they've done the research and
this is incredible give well as matching
donations from first-time donors dollar
for dollar up to a hundred dollars just
click on the link that's on screen right
now or in the description to donate and
on the donation page when asked about
where you heard about givewell choose
YouTube and legal eagle or again to have
up to a hundred dollars matched just
click on the link below and after that
click on this box over here for more
legal eagle or I'll see you in court